[Musique]
assurément on peut parler du télétravail
une réussite pour assise pour permettre
la continuité de service et pour
permettre aux collaborateurs et aux
entreprises continuent leurs activités
pour autant ça n'a pas été que des
réussites sur tous les plans puisque on
a vu quand même à la suite du premier
confinement un certain nombre d'effets
négatifs du télétravail il ya une toutes
les expertises qui ont été faites ont
mis en évidence un décalage fort entre
les entreprises qui avaient déjà conclu
des accord sur le télétravail et qui
avaient des salariés qui pratiquait le
télétravail et puis les entreprises qui
n'avaient rien prévu rien anticipé et
ont placé leurs salariés et des travail
complètement improvisé qui s'est traduit
par une dégradation forte des conditions
de travail avec différentes études dont
une qu'on a lu a été publié récemment
dans l'empreinte humaine qui a mis en
évidence en fait les problèmes
sanitaires a déposé notamment sur le
l'aspect psychologique puisque les
médecins constatent une augmentation
significative des prescriptions
d'antidépresseurs et de problèmes
psychologiques dans le cadre de du
confinement et plus particulièrement le
télétravail qui a été un facteur
aggravant
par rapport à cette situation
le télétravail en fait ne s'improvise
pas d'où la nécessité de formation mais
d'où aussi la nécessité d'avoir un cadre
clair c'est ce qu'avait pointés
d'ailleurs la concertation 2017 sur le
télétravail texte signé par toutes les
organisations syndicales et toutes les
organisations patronales qui avait listé
cet sujet pour en fait compléter la ni
de 2005 qui existait sur le télétravail
à partir de sujets comme par exemple les
questions de management qui ont été
évoqués mais aussi la question du droit
à la déconnexion le sujet qui n'existait
pas en 2005 mais qui aujourd'hui avec le
développement du travail à distance et
les outils de communication est un sujet
central
c'est à ça qu'il faut qu'on s'attelle et
malheureusement le texte qu'on a en
france qui fut des négociations qu'on a
déjà eu du mal à obtenir puisque le
patronat ne voulait pas d'un nouvel
annie sur le télétravail
ce nouveau texte qui est proposée à la
signature jusqu'au 23 décembre
malheureusement est un texte ni normatif
ni prescriptif qui est simplement un
guide de bonnes pratiques comme le
souhaitait le patronat et qui
malheureusement ne va permettre de te
derrien clarifier du tout puisqu'il
renvoie à la négociation à l'entreprise
tout ce qui pourrait être mis en oeuvre
sans aucun cadre
alors oui je l'admets mais comme un
risque plus que comme une critique
systématiser parce que bien sûr que ce
risque existe mais mais pour partie de
manière inconsciente et pour partie
aussi du côté de certains collaborateurs
je veux dire par là que comme monsieur
moulin seul évoqué le télétravail doit
se construire c'est un projet de co
création avec les collaborateurs
quand c'est pas fun on peut aller au
delà on a évoqué les horaires de travail
qui lorsqu'elles ne sont pas cadrées
peuvent amener le collaborateur au
dollar
de son travail habituel mais parfois de
son propre ferait donc il faut il faut
vraiment vraiment cadrés pour éviter les
abus des managers et pour éviter aussi
pour protéger aussi les collaborateurs
contre eux et contre leur difficulté à
discerner la nécessité de s'arrêter
excellent on parle beaucoup d'un effet
de qui s'appelle l'éphèbe le ring c'est
quand on ne sait plus faire la
différence entre l'espace personnel
et l'espace professionnel quand vous
travaillez chez vous vous avez un
mélange des genres qui psychologiquement
est très dur à gérer donc le risque est
réel
après est ce que c'est une volonté
générale des entreprises
moi je n'ai pas observé j'ai travaillé
avec des entreprises qui étaient très
précautionneuse de protéger leurs
collaborateurs d'autres qui l'étaient un
peu moins certaines ne l'étant pas du
tout d'où la nécessité effectivement
d'avoir des accords cadres qui oblige
tout le monde à passer par la création
commune de ce temps de télétravail qui
n'est plus un télétravail une certaine
manière subi une donc pathologique mais
qui devient un télétravail construit
donc accepté dans une logique de gagnant
gagnant et les enquêtes que l'on a donc
que ce chemin vers le gagnant gagnant
est possible paradis à condition qu'il
ya un cadre qui permette aux parties
prenantes de construire ensemble dans
leurs intérêts à chacune
cet espace le télétravail mais en
quelques mois un second peut souhaiter
c'est que on s'inspire de ce qui se fait
ailleurs en europe
tu parle par exemple du portugal de
l'espagne où des pays nordiques que
comme le danemark
qui eux ont un cadre défini pour le
télétravail et qui justement permettent
d'avoir un cadre protecteur par rapport
à tous les abus qui sont possibles et la
normalité c'est de récompenser les
entreprises qui justement un respecte un
cadre de ce type là c'est pas de laisser
toute liberté à des entreprises qui vont
avoir un comportement irresponsable par
rapport à la mise en oeuvre de nouvelles
formes de travail comme le télétravail